[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
happy thursday it's officially the
second half of the nba season and we
sprint towards the finish
giving out picks giving out free money
from fanduel
and a few hoodies along the way you just
tapped into the group chat live in the
bleacher report app
presented by fanduel my name is kathy
richards our franchise player
with the franchise tag like chris godwin
is our betting expert kelly stewart
and the babyface assassin putting up
three-pointers from 43 feet away like in
the all-star game
is greg ivory kells there are a hundred
million
basketball games on tonight and i know
you care about greg and i can you just
remind us about
late night chasing please
what caps today has been a good day so
far on the college basketball slate so
much so that i had to cram for the nba
show i love days like these but remember
bankroll management don't go too crazy
and especially if you start to lose
early on there's no reason to be betting
pac-12
after dark the big sky conference shout
out to
our old buddy west he played in the big
sky conference but it's true
just you know don't go crazy we got a
lot of weeks ahead of us we got a good
nba slate tonight
just uh money management guys yes
perfect and there's no better place to
start
than each week our chuck vs america
segment where we we
pick uh prop that's head to head against
the hall of famer charles barkley
and last week you voted to take new
orleans versus miami in the race to 10.
the tenney in america didn't work out so
well for us
getting ready for all-star break as well
oh man duncan robinson how can you do
this to us man
how can you do this to us oh you know
what that was his only three point in
the game too
so we lost the tenney we took an al
america charles barkley took an l
america
and we're currently if we look at the
standings ten and two
chuck is there at six and six so we
still have a comfortable lead
a four four game lead but it's another
day and another opportunity
to get a w and a few hoodies so i want
to salute
jaylen brunson a former champion at
villanova
and current member of the dallas
mavericks when he tweeted recently
immaculate vibes only
so we need some immaculate vibes
only from the audience g-money
cabbie i love the immaculate vibe
i like immaculate sunset yes i like
immaculate sunset so i mean i'm rocking
with the immaculate vibes
uh but if you guys are new to the show i
want to introduce you to something
this right here is called the handy
dandy ipad and this is how you receive
the hoodies cabbie kelly i'm in the
comments looking for some takes
uh i got njc6
they say greg hook meet up with a hoodie
they're rocking with the over on uh joe
harris to score
over three and a half uh to make over
three and a half points
shout out to you you're walking away
with hoodie i'm gonna move on cabbie uh
here we go
i have they're spamming the comments i
got bad sports takes is like just going
back back back
back that's not how you win a hoodie
caviar i'm gonna give away one more
i got uh i got i got
b-i-l-a-r-r-a-z-a i i'm not gonna
butcher that
the producer's got that whatever it is
94
he says dude a br hoodie is all i want
there will be
two threes in the first three minutes it
is going to happen
i love that for your prediction you're
walking away
with the hoodie all right happy let's
get this thing on the road absolutely
g-money you
you mentioned joe harris so in tonight's
chuck versus america
we're gonna go right there with joe
harris the brooklyn nets
flamethrower so we asked you on twitter
earlier today
will joe harris make over three and a
half
three-pointers you see the poll there we
put it on twitter
and america is voting yes with 53
of the voters very close joe harris is
shooting 51
from three-point range this season 51
so greg how confident other than
blizzard blizzard
94 how confident is the rest of the
audience that this one hits
over three and a half three-pointers
from joe harris
cabbie let me ask them audience i need
you guys
to let me know are you rocking with the
over or the under here
joe harris three points uh over three
and a half
three pointers made today are you
working with the over yonder get
creative in the comments give me gifts
give me uh emojis are there any jokes
over
or under inside i mean give me a joe
harris gift why not
fill those comments up but i want to
talk to kelly i want to talk to kelly
do you see any value in the plus 138
on the oversight do you see any value
here with joe harris
greg the good thing about joe harris is
you know you're going to get at least
three from him right the last time he
didn't hit three three-pointers in a
game was
february 15th so my dude's on fire we
know that he's gonna take
those attempts now the under is probably
what's gonna hit but i am not
under any circumstances laying minus
178. that's not good
no i'm gonna take the plus 138 here and
hope that he can get to four
we know he's gonna have the open looks
we know he's gonna have the opportunity
we just need that ball to fall
give me the over plus 138 i like that
kelly yeah nice one
66 of his actual shots are three point
shots so every
two out of three are from downtown and
he's hit
three three-pointers in the game ten
times and he's hit
four or more 14 times this season so i'm
absolutely rocking with joe harris to
hit
four or more three-point shots against
boston today
which is a team's okay defense but
brooklyn is rolling right now winning
10 of 11. so let's go joe harris let's
light it up
g-money who's riding
cabbie i got c lewis uh 27 is rocking
with the over i just want you to see the
gift that he got joe harris cleaning the
screen right there
shouts out to uc lewis 27 you are
walking away with
jay lewis 67
uh says joe harris over all day
team greg shout out to you you're
walking away with hoodie uh here we go
i got max rexel with a gift
he got a joe harris gift let me show you
guys shout out to you max you are
walking uh oh there
there it is yeah shout out to you max
you're walking away woody uh here we go
cabbie let me give away one more i got
jim 910 joe harris the flame
the flame blower will go under for
tonight
just for tonight though just for tonight
though the attempts will be there
but i got james harden getting a triple
double let's go
next shout out to you jimmy910
and your take i'm not rocking with your
joe harris take but i love
love love the analysis that you gave us
in your comment and you rock it with
james harden
with a triple double but let me tell the
people why i think james
james uh joe harris i'm sorry will go
over
three and a half three pointers there's
a man that's on their team by the name
of kevin durant
i don't think he's playing today so that
means he's gonna bring weeks greg
there's gonna be more opportunities
follow me up follow me up okay
the people wanna let me let me talk to
the people
well there's gonna be more opportunities
for joe harris to have the ball in his
hands
with that being said he's gonna put the
ball he's gonna shoot the ball more
take me over here rock with kelly cabby
and me
riding me over all right i'll talk to
y'all man uh okay so america
check out the pre-game show on inside
the nba at 7 p.m eastern to hear
if chuck is going to ride with us or
he's going to fade us
and likely take another l and make sure
you get on fanduel
and bet joe harris over three and a half
three-pointers
if you're rocking with us america so we
all know that
the 3x2 is the best bet in america kelly
said it last week
fanduel is just giving away free money
if there was a gift
one of these this is what fanduel is
giving away giving
in the three by two so will there be two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes of tonight's
boston vs brooklyn game last week we
took the 3x2
in new orleans and and miami so we want
to say thank you
and thank kelly olynyk this could be a
collective effort for the pelicans
ko from
[Music]
[Applause]
18 and 10 in that game and it was four
for five from downtown g buddy
salute hey all my all my 2k players all
my 2k players know what the green dot is
cabbie kelly
and 2k when you get that green dot you
know the ball is going in
on those two shots from kelly gray
please don't act like cabbie doesn't
know what 2k
is cabbie is in 2k i might he is cabbie
is and
he hasn't took it but but yeah those two
shots that were just made those are
green dots green dot
green dot tonight we're looking at the
boston and brooklyn game at 7 30.
uh g-money tap in with your army we need
more people on board let's get it
[Music]
oh cabbie i mean they already know what
to do
when when this comes up when we see
three by two we already know we're
rocking with the yes
look at here i need you guys to get
creative in the comments just say yes
but say it in different languages why
not say it in
emojis if you can say it in text if you
can just get creative say
yes kelly i ask you this every week
[Music]
i i just submitted you i just submitted
on on the app does that count
that was my answer uh i mean i can't see
what you said
i'm i'm just just tell the people just
tell people
are you writing are you not writing 11
eyes you said a different language
that's all i got let's be honest um we
go over this every single week greg
you never listen to me so why would i
expect you to listen to me this week
yes we're going to bet yes on the 3x2
and if you guys listened to me last week
we would have won the race to 10 but
nobody wanted to listen to me
so please listen to me here and bet the
3x2 get the free money from our friends
at fanduel
you're welcome it'll help make up for
all those chase bets on the big sky
conference tournament
nuggets all day listen boston doesn't
really come out firing
from three-point lane so it's probably
going to be uh brooklyn
shouldering the load to hit those two
three-pointers so that's joe harris
hopefully by joe harris yeah joe harris
or connery irving or james harden they
they can all
shoot shoot the lights out so i'm riding
yes three by two
mostly because of brooklyn but hey if
jason tatum wants to splash one
in the first three minutes i'm not mad
at that but let's get it it's a yes for
me
gimani who's riding with us in the three
by two tonight celtics and nets
richie richie 21 says c
c yes that means he's rocking shout out
to you richie you were walking away with
it
eddie on the go you need some french in
there is there a wii in there
eddie i'm gonna look for that cabbie but
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm
i'm shouting out all my spanish spanish
speakers here i got eddie on the go
saying see
senor c senor he's rocking with a yes
uh let me let me just go to somebody
else that sent the gif
i got grucci grucci not gucci but grucci
is rocking with uh fallon he's rocking
with fallon and saying yes look at the
gift look at the look at the gift
yeah nice yeah there it is there it is
uh
cabbie i'm gonna give away one more why
not
let me give away one more why not
remy yohoche raymioche
23 says no those are bad vibes
but i think my favorite part of the show
is watching greg read
uh people's handles because i'm terrible
at it too
and this just makes me feel better about
myself it's okay i i
went to college and i graduated i
guarantee that but anyway
greg brady know that you and i can't
read the handles so it's just
too hard raymie but i just
i gotta talk about raymie though because
i told everybody to say yes and
they said no and that's bad vibes and
that's not immaculate vibes that's not
sunset vibes that's
totally going against the grain but look
at here we treat
things like this with kindness so i'm
going to give you a hoodie shouts out to
you
no okay no no no no he's getting it no
we do not reward bad behavior on the
show
it's it's kelly it's a done deal signed
sealed delivered we are giving raymie a
hoodie
shout out to you ravi but we are riding
the yes
definitely and in order to get the three
by two check out our vr betting socials
for the links
to to the to fanduel and the three by
two so what's happening with that and
since the three by two has been cashing
more than damian lillard in the fourth
quarter
we're pleased to announce free by
tuesday
we are expanding the three months it's
no longer just thursdays
it is now tuesdays so tap it with g
money
on br betting social channels on
tuesdays
and thursdays and go for a ride it's the
most fun you're gonna have
betting sports and just because three
the three by two is sweeping the nation
fanduel is offering a bonus three by two
to the homies in illinois tonight bulls
sixers you can get the 3x2 tonight on
fanduel
if you live in illinois so tap in with
our social channel to get the link
and definitely tap in with fanduel uh to
get that experience um
so there you go hammer that every day
you can every way you can
there's been some big band movement in
the nba the past couple of days
and as if the brooklyn nets weren't
stacked enough
they just added a five-time all-nba
player
in blake griffin andre drummond and
lamarcus aldridge are still out there
but right now the brooklyn nets are
inching towards
being the favorite to win the nba
championship
let's check the futures offered by
fanduel as far as
who is going to win it all the los
angeles lakers are up top there at plus
280
brooklyn nets at plus 300 the clippers
still in the mix of plus 550
the bucks jazz sixers celtics nuggets
pluses i don't see the miami
i don't see kelly's miami heat on there
but anyway
those are the updated odds uh
i can't believe the lakers are still the
favorite okay so the nets roster
the next roster i cannot just believe
the lakers are still the favorite so
g-money do you see a lot do you still
see a lot of l.a in the comments either
clippers or lakers
cabbie you know what let me ask them
first let me ask them let me let them
let me let it marinate a little bit okay
uh let me ask them
hey guys tell me who you are
betting to win it all this year get it
in the comments give me gifts give me
takes
give me you know text give me emojis
whatever you feel comfortable doing
give it to me in the comments i'm going
to let you guys uh i'm going to give
away t-shirts no no not t-shirts hoodies
cabbies goodies
not t-shirts but hoodies and uh
kelly talk to the people let us know
who are you still
with the same team before the all-star
break or did you switch it up
i didn't switch it up but you're
absolutely right look i was really low
on this nets team i didn't think they
were going to gel i thought steve nash
was going to be in a world of hurt
trying to manage all these personalities
does blake griffin really make them a
championship team
not necessarily he didn't really move
the odds
he doesn't really shake things up but
he's not going to be a detriment to this
team so congratulations to them they're
still not going to win at all greg
and yes the miami heat have won a few
games here and there
but they're still really under achieving
unless jimmy butler
really helps me out or like kelly olynyk
in that pelicans game
every once in a while i get thrown a
bone with this heat team but they're
just
not clicking a team that is still
clicking the utah
jazz i can't help but think that they're
still being undervalued here they're
still getting no respect
look i said the nuggets out of the west
i said the heat out of the east the
nuggets
not going to be the team out of the west
this team doesn't want to play defense
yes the joker's got it
but they are really missing a few guys
and michael porter jr
just isn't really stepping up like he
did in the bubble last year
if he somehow can turn things around
maybe my nuggets to get still alive
but as of right now i'm on the jazz jazz
bandwagon
for your lakers opinion there greg the
reason why the lakers are still the
favor is because once anthony davis
comes back
this team is going to be a force to
reckon with so bookmakers don't want to
overreact to him being gone for the last
three weeks
and possibly drop the odds let's say to
four or five to one because guess what's
gonna happen
they're gonna get inundated with lakers
money more so than they already have
been particularly geographically here in
las vegas
so they're holding steady saying hey
look the lakers are the favorite until
somebody shows us otherwise
you know i i totally agree with you
there cows and
i was wondering if the lakers continue
to lose what in anthony davis's absence
will the line move but you just said
probably not because uh the sports books
have already taken
i think it would have to be i i
truly i think anthony davis would have
to be out for like another month for
them to
really start to over adjust from that
because we know
what you're getting with lebron we know
there's plenty of depth on that bench
and at any given night this lakers team
can turn it on but
anthony davis is the best player on that
team no disrespect to lebron james he is
the man that is going to get those w's
for that lakers team and without him
right now they're just really hurting
so with a couple of other big men just
floating out there or just waiting to be
signed andre drummond and lamarcus
aldridge these guys will probably sign
with contenders
because who's going to handle joel
embiid
in the play in the finals you need to
throw bodies at joel embiid the way that
the lakers threw bodies at nikola jokic
like dwight howard and javale mcgee in
order to get to
pass the western conference finals into
the finals and then try to neutralize
bam and a bio i still like the sixers
because they brought in some shooting
and namely seth curry and danny green
tobias harris is
he's been actually shooting shooting
better i think this is philly's year
because they were embarrassed last year
in the bubble went out in a sweep to bro
to the boston celtics in the first round
i think it's philly's year give me
philadelphia plus 1200. uh g-money
anybody riding or is everybody still
riding with la in the comments
i see you mixed i see mixed signals in
the comments cabbie i see a lot of jazz
actually i see a lot of jazz uh i
i got uh joey and joe yan says don't
[ __ ] my jazz
uh shout out to you jo yin i got jazz oh
i got my comments just went away but i'm
back i'm back
josh campbell josh campbell 98 said
jazz are overrated and always a regular
season team
can't compete in the playoffs nets or
clear winners shout out to you josh you
were walking away with hoodie
uh toot the world says brooklyn or the
lake show
shout out to you too i mean you did just
take the favorites but
i gave a good take so shout out to you
you're walking away with hoodie uh
dina slugger uh they're rocking with you
cabbie they say yes mr unstoppable
embiid um shout out to you dina slugger
you are walking away with a hoodie eddie
on the go says
embiid is the beast cabbie he's agreeing
with you um
i got one more cabbie one more and then
then i'll just call it that all right
one more then i'll just call it that
i got vcg 2710
he got the the gift the gift going
rocking with kelly you see the you see
the jazz right there that's mike
connolly
you guys do not know like he's got the
little dance going i like it
got the little dance going got the
little dance going but i'm dancing right
now let me tell y'all while i'm dancing
okay
because at the beginning of the year i
told you guys show one i was rocking
with the nets
strictly because of kevin durant he's
the best show for
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure it was
the first time we ever talked about
futures
anyway anyway uh
i said kevin durant's the one of the
best players in the league right now
still think that when he's healthy he
since that time cabbie and kelly he
added james harden
not only did he add james harden to the
squad but they just added blake griffin
that is two former all-stars james
harden was just an all-star this year
right to the team
right there's that question still
remains yeah they're stacked offensive
but
who's gonna play defense my dude and
then also
you're adding another personality into
that mix
like that is so many different big
personalities
locker room who's playing defense come
on now who's playing
come on those guys those guys join
together for
one goal to win a championship those are
all stars on that team you don't think
they're going to
figure it out you don't think they're
going to fake i'm drawing out they
literally have a whole roster of
all-stars on their team they're going to
figure it out but my thing is
i got this i got the nets before the
trades
i'm loving it even more after the trades
give me brooklyn any day uh i think
they're going to win it all
i'll put my money on them right now and
i did before the before the season
speaking let's go okay so speaking of
putting money on something uh
you still have a 500 bet with our
franchise player kelly stewart about
hitting a same game parlay
greg we we've stopped uh keeping track
of of your record
uh because it's starting to feel mean um
and if listen
if by some chance your lucky number is
11 then maybe this is your week because
you are and i said we weren't keeping
track anymore but because you are owen
10
so far this year in whoa in picking
a five-point same game parley so tonight
you're locking in
okay golden state warriors against their
divisional rivals
la clippers so give us the five legs my
dude and uh
we'll see how this thing plays out well
first well first before i give you the
five like let's
throw up last one oh yeah ticket two
weeks just so you guys can see
more more greens than than reds yeah
okay okay
i just got to say something so you bet
50 of parlay
you're 010. why can't i book these why
does fanduel gonna put these in like
then i would just be free rolling on me
and greg season bet right now
but kelsey you don't do play
yeah i know but i would take greg's
action all day long look at that
look at that all right kelly how about
we just single bed it and then we can uh
you know
talk talk about that i already told you
i already told you that weeks ago you
need to be single betting these because
you do
do well three and two is making moneys
are so cheap see though
a lot i mean i look our audience no more
great
you're like 12 to 1. they're juicy
though no
way no 12-1 is not juicy a five-team
parlay pays 22-1
and very rarely are greg's parlays even
22-1
kelly you should have said that episode
one you should have said that episode
one because my goal from now
until the end of the season is just to
see one go through the net
that's all i want to do is see one go
through the net with that being said
we're gonna go right into it
we're gonna get right into it are you
guys ready
let's go kawhi leonard the claw
the dog himself kawhi leonard we uh
we're rocking with over
four assists over four assists for kauai
i do see him
what is that minus 225 just go be
yourself kawhi
just go be yourself gopi go out there be
yourself
uh go go make a couple couple dish
dish passes and go be yourself and we're
moving on
moving on to the clippers first half
money line i see this as a lock
take it clippers first half money line
i'm a warriors fan gabby and i'm being
honest i don't see the words winning
this game i see them getting off to a
slow start and then
i see the clippers you know fresh legs
after the all-star game coming off
starting off hot all right so i'm
rocking with the the first half
money line moving on to my guy steph
curry
my guy steph curry i'm gonna go
over four assists i just need steph to
just go out there
draw a little attention find a couple
guys that are open and
and just make some shots warriors make
make a couple shots i do think steph
is gonna uh gonna get over four assists
i mean he can throw a couple lives to
james weisman i can see it
happening steph i'm rocking with you to
go over
four assists uh moving on
now this one was a little tricky here
this one was a little tricky i was
trying to figure out if i want to go
under or over but i'm gonna go
over for the game i'm gonna go over for
the game total throw it up there so the
people can see
over 230. over 230 guys yeah
i see this being a high scoring game a
little back and forth back and forth
up and down um go go get some buckets
guys
so give me the over here and then to end
it i'm going back to the chef
i'm going back to curry curry go grab
some rebounds
go grab some reba i need four four
pl uh four over rebounds for curry i see
this happening cabbie
uh he's sneaky he's sneaky very sneaky
he's sneaky with his shot timeout
timeout time is rebound before the
producer puts up the ticket what does
this pay like eight to one
i haven't even seen this like let's have
him put up the ticket
so we can show we let's have him put up
the ticket let's show kelly with this
pace
because she wants to know
are you better even worse
i would be nice when i said eight to one
wow what a trash
ticket ray we're just trying to win
we are just trying to win yeah so so
wait it
this this operates on two levels because
greg wins
the same game parlay for what was what
was the value of the ticket there if
this hits
i'm gonna have the producers pick it out
because i said it had to be at least 15
to one so i'm done with this trash hold
on all right i got a show with mikey
locks to do so let's
give out some hoodies and move along
okay so it's so the ticket
you get about 300 bucks on the ticket
but then you also get
500 from kelly if it hits so that's like
800 no you don't
no you don't i said weeks ago when you
have that trash eight to one ticket
there is some there's five team repays
22 to one
this is like him betting nets money line
at the
at the cell phone wait you can't rent
like
[Music]
the director because he got he's got the
text i'm like no more trash tickets i'm
not playing this game
oh actually this has been fun he checked
uh i just the the producer just
whispered in my ears
whatever he wants he checks to has not
checked the tapes from five weeks ago
the last trash ticket you had
so kelly's telling the producer that he
didn't okay wait
gotcha hold on listen to the freaking
group text
group chat just things get gold side so
have the terms been to go
the terms have to be negotiated between
you and greg and you guys have to agree
to negotiate the terms you can't have
just one party be agreed to be like no
i'm not this isn't
these aren't the terms because you guys
said the original term my things
my things happened
how big of a long shot whether it's plus
five gabby
a five-team parlay when you walk up to a
window at a sportsbook pays
22-1 when you bet five legs that are
minus one
ten i was told he had to hit a five-team
parlay
he's trying to be trash and the oh stuff
over forces
truck stuff over four rebounds these are
all minus 200
plus tickets that's cool go ahead he's
still not going to win go ahead
wait are you she saw it
because we're going to see one go in
we're going to see one go in and i want
my 500.
please thank you i got cash at venmo
whatever however you want to do it kelly
i just want to see the 500 after this
one goes in
okay i don't uh all right let's just
okay
we're gonna have to we're going to
handle this to the show
because we have some we have to
basketball picks to lock it so
um thanks for joining us on on the
family family squabbles here on group
chat presented by daniel
what you learned today um make sure to
uh the terms and conditions of your
friendly vets with your wagers
uh joe harris before you walk away
before you walk away
make sure you start booking the sports
kids by your friends
with your little brother you never want
to name greg at the sports book
hear me out at the sports book when you
walk away you you're away for five
minutes does the sports book let you
change your bet
no but when you walk up there and you
better fight it's 22-1
i don't think so so kelly um
you about to be owed me some money well
listen i'm gonna keep my comments to
myself i'm gonna side text it to cabbie
in our own group chat
and he's gonna be pissed at you
okay so yeah suddenly pay attention to
the terms and conditions of friendly
wagers between friends
uh joe harris is an absolute uh
superhero from downtown
and the three by two offer from fanduel
is available on
tuesdays and thursdays so to loot
so salute to our friends and fanduel
alongside kelly stewart
and greg ivory my name is gabby richards
we are leaving the group chat please
shout out to the comments they ride with
me kelly stay right with me
comment set they write with me what's
that with you greg
let's go thanks for joining us so see
you guys on tuesday
[Music]
you